esta es la casa del imán hassan y que
usan un influyente el líder espiritual
marroquí al que el gobierno francés
quiere expulsar pero cuando la policía
llegó para detener al imán este martes
no encontraron a nadie un revés para el
gobierno y el ministro de interior que
horas antes saludó la decisión del
máximo tribunal administrativo francés
de respaldar la expulsión es una
victoria para francia de interés general
no es una victoria partidista o política
esta detención fallida es la última
vuelta de tuerca en un caso que el
gobierno presentó como símbolo de su
lucha contra el radicalismo el imán al
que se considera cercano a los hermanos
musulmanes ha hecho comentarios
antisemitas homófobos y sexistas en sus
sermones y ha sido señalado como posible
amenaza para la seguridad a principios
de agosto sin embargo un tribunal de
parís bloqueó su deportación diciendo
que era una medida desproporcionada sus
partidarios y su abogado aseguran que
nunca ha sido procesado por radicalismo
ni que se tome unas dicen que este
hombre es peligroso por lo que ha dicho
en vídeos en línea pero la expulsión
ayudará a mantener el orden público
del auto
el imán tiene la intención de luchar
contra su orden de expulsión en los
tribunales acusado por la oposición de
mal manejo del caso el ministro de
interior afirmó que las autoridades han
expulsado a casi 800 extremistas
extranjeros desde que manuel macrón está
en el poder